CBP CUSTODY.
>> EVERY AMERICAN CITY IS NOW A
BORDER CITY.
FENTANYL IS NOW THE LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH FOR AMERICANS
BETWEEN THE AGES OF 18 AND 45.
BIDEN'S OPEN BORDER POLICIES
ARE KILLING AMERICANS.
WHY IS THE WHITE HOUSE NOT
TREATING THIS LIKE THE CRISIS
IT IS?
>> Trace: FENTANYL IS POISONING
AND KILLING HUNDREDS OF
AMERICANS EVERY DAY AS MEXICAN
DRUG CARTELS TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE CHAOS AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THE WHITE HOUSE STILL REFUSING
TO DO WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
STOP THEM.
THE FORMER ACTING DIRECTOR OF
ICE AND FORMER CHIEF OF THE
U.S. BORDER PATROL.
RON, GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON.
300 AMERICANS A DAY ROUGHLY
DYING OF OPIOID OVERDOSE.
MOST OF THOSE FENTANYL.
THE WHITE HOUSE AND JOE BIDEN
DIDN'T MENTION IT AT ALL LAST
NIGHT.
IT GETS WORSE, RON, THE WHITE
HOUSE IS NOW, YOU KNOW,
INSULTING AMERICA'S
INTELLIGENCE BY TELLING THEM
THAT PEOPLE AREN'T JUST WALKING
ACROSS THE BORDER, IT IS NOT
HAPPENING.
>> THEY HAVE NO CREDIBILITY ON
THIS ISSUE.
THE PRESIDENT CAN'T USE HIS
PRIME TIME SPEECH TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH FENTANYL
AND DRUG OVERDOSES WILL ACCOUNT
FOR OVER 100,000 DEATHS IN THE
UNITED STATES THIS YEAR.
SO HE CAN'T TALK ABOUT FENTANYL
OR ALL THE DRUGS COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER FROM MEXICO.
THAT'S WHERE 90 PLUS% OF THEM
COME FROM.
HE CAN'T TALK ABOUT THE 700
PLUS PEOPLE DYING IN THE
PIPELINE TRYING TO CROSS THAT
BORDER BECAUSE HE WILL HAVE TO
BRING ATTENTION TO THE DISASTER
THAT THEY'VE CREATED BY PULLING
DOWN ALL THE POLICIES THAT WERE
WORKING AT THE SOUTHWEST BORDER
AND CONTROLLING THAT BORDER.
WHEN THIS PRESIDENT TOOK OVER,
45 YEAR LOWS IN TRAFFIC ALONG
THE SOUTHWEST BORDER.
WE HAVE A DEMAND PROBLEM WITH
DRUGS.
FENTANYL IS KILLING PEOPLE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
THEY'RE TAKING IT.
THEY'RE BUYING DRUGS OFF THE
DARK WEB AND STREET CORNER AND
DON'T KNOW THEY TAKE FENTANYL
INSIDE SOMETHING ELSE.
IT IS A BIG PROBLEM.
THEY HAVE TO AVOID IT BECAUSE
IT BRINGS ATTENTION TO THE
DISASTER THAT IS AT THE BORDER.
>> Dana: RON, THEY DID ANSWER A
QUESTION FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
FROM PETER DOOCY EARLIER THIS
WEEK.
WE'VE BEEN SHOWING ALL WEEK.
THIS IS A MAP SHOWING THE
FENTANYL GATE WAYS INTO THE
UNITED STATES FROM MEXICO.
AND THEN YOU HAD KARINE
JEAN-PIERRE THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY SAY FENTANYL
SEIZURES ARE UP BY 200%.
SHE SAID SO THAT PROVES THAT WE
ARE DOING ALL THAT WE NEED TO
DO BECAUSE THE CBP HAS ACTUALLY
SEIZED THIS MUCH FENTANYL.
HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND TO HER
SAYING THAT THEY'VE DONE THEIR
JOB?
>> I'M GRATEFUL THERE ARE
PEOPLE OUT THERE BORDER PATROL,
CBP, DPS ARE PROTECTING US FROM
THE POISON.
LET'S NOT PRETEND THE DISASTER
GOING ON AT THE BORDER IS
SOMEHOW DOESN'T EXIST BECAUSE
WE MADE MORE SEIZURES THAN WE
DID LAST YEAR.
THE REASON THERE IS MORE
FENTANYL IN THE PIPELINE IS
BECAUSE THE CARTELS ARE
BECOMING MORE AND MORE BOLD
BECAUSE THEY ESSENTIALLY
CONTROL THE TRAFFIC ACROSS THE
BORDER BETWEEN THE PORTS OF
ENTRY.
YES, GREAT WE CATCH IT BUT IT
IS NOT EVERYTHING.
WHEN THE HIGHWAY PATROL GOES
OUT AND WRITES THREE SPEEDING
TICKETS THEY DON'T TELL THE
PEOPLE THEY WORK FOR KNOW ONE
ON THE HIGHWAY IS BREAKING THE
SPEED LIMIT.
IT'S NOT HOW IT WORKS.
I'M GLAD THEY'RE DOING WHAT
THEY CAN BUT MUCH MORE NEEDS TO
BE DONE.
WHAT IS THE PLAN FOR THE BORDER?
WILL WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
PER MONTH CROSSING THE BORDER
AND GIVING CARTELS MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS A DAY?
>> Trace: THAT'S THE QUESTION
THERE.
WHAT IS THE PLAN?
WHAT IS THE REMEDY FOR THIS?
YOU JUST CAN'T LET THIS KEEP
HAPPENING.
YOU HAVE DEMOCRATS SAYING OH,
THE CARTELS ARE SMUGGLING THIS
THROUGH BORDER PORTS AND
ENTRIES AND STUFF.
IT IS NOT TRUE.
WE SEE THIS EVERY DAY.
THEY ARE SENDING DRUG MULES
ACROSS WITH A LOT OF THIS
FENTANYL EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> PEOPLE WHO DON'T WANT TO
PROTECT THE BOARD ARE SAY THAT
EVERYTHING IS COMING THROUGH
THE PORT.
DON'T THINK FOR A MINUTE THESE
CARTELS WILL CHANGE THEIR
BUSINESS MODEL.
IF THEY CAN'T GET IT THROUGH
THE PORT THEY'LL SMUGGLE IT
UNDERGROUND.
WE'VE SEEN TUNNELS ACROSS THE
SOUTHWEST BORDER.
PEOPLE THAT DON'T WANT TO
PATROL OR PROTECT THE BORDER
SAY IT'S COMING THROUGH THE
PORTS.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THEY MAKE SEIZURES AT THE PORT
BUT IT'S N